we'll have the lead at the break the
question will be by how much
[Applause]
Magruder is a savvy player how do you
defend that well I mean my thing is this
how many times do you see people block
three points up shots
see if the Rockets can convert that
defense to some points Austin Rivers
great move inside with the left hand got
it
[Applause]
Chamberlin playing with the six-foot
undertale
what a move there Austin is totally
shakes his defender and then with the
left endpoints for him
[Applause]
crossed over Tudor agility on melon
juice
[Applause]
[Music]
James are conflicted Pella eight
straight for Houston this path between
hardens legs prove a few possessions ago
what a great pass through his own five
hole through the pocket there to compel
it for the dump he's probably gonna
spend some time moving back and forth
but Otto Porter is out of the foot spray
and dunk it down how about that pass
look at this over the top Pass Capella's
open so hardens got to find a way to get
[Applause]
[Music]
hello else to give both in the penalty
under two to play Hardin step back
what's up the three got hit chats good
James Harden double team than a chance
for a four-point play Jesus look at the
crowd and settle I think he is it all of
himself at this point don't reach
because he's gonna preach and then
you're forced to close out heart drives
dunks Oh baby another look at the drive
and slam for James Harden
[Music]
with her again to the basket and capella
says get that stuff out of here
participation he says the hunted my
house French oh he's right there
he's another serving his third years
good capela look at Jardin he's got two
guys on him he knows he's got homes on
him so Capella's got to be open
somewhere the woodlands church supermo
shows you what a great pass over the
shoulder that was to compel us
to the basket
[Applause]
report turning on the Jets of the three
good luck
you know you choose shopper Westlaw and
he went by buddy he liked and were
standing in mud and that's what
Westbrook brings to the rocket a lot of
Orlando players let's see it part it
combo combining for 16 in the first and
right into your living room Westbrook
with the flush individually but to for
this myth scene because that was a major
reason why their reverse follow
beautifully done and this is the thing
when you watch Russell Westbrook going
to the basket everyone is collapsing in
over
[Applause]
well they go hard Stein the first ones
on the alley-oop
he had a follow up in front of the
basket backwards are you kidding me
Hartstein saying you know what I get
some opportunity to show the coach I can
get it done
Bing up his head even though Westbrook
has missed the last couple of shots of
Jeff it's tough to shoot when you've got
dislocated fingers on your shooting and
I think since healed
Simmons inside had it blocked by compel
at the rim with the bait away off the
mark
Westbrook on the move great pass anytime
capela who punches it on NB and
Westbrook in transitions great vision
and great run by capela Paris at a
parsley block
the runner
[Applause]
great advanced baths by Harden
so Westbrook who emphatically slams it
home
[Applause]
and they gave a salute 57 to go another
slammer for Capelli's got 20 pounds
being out and he's really showing them
he's got three years ago account for
more it is he shoots he scores and then
hard to get by everybody yeah at the big
James black Capello Martin comes up with
a loose ball
Capello running the floor drives kicks
it out Tucker for free to stop the drive
that get the LOB and then capela with a
great block harden just throws it ahead
and here comes capela runnin past Howard
and then finally the beautiful vision to
see Tucker
double arracourt leaving austin rivers
wide open now take a look at austin
rivers missing the three danuel house
with the three run down the paint the
Jazz had double dare in court so Austin
was wide open and nobody box-out danuel
house meanwhile Fordland after carmelo
anthony was filed by Hardman got just
one score in its first 10 possession and
his effectiveness on the defensive end
that's the athleticism look at the ups
we touched on how at times they share
the ball it's beautiful execution Wow
Ben McLemore smashes it right over
Jackson Hayes as you have to be
competitive to be successful at this
level but Russ is probably the most now
here is James Hortons lob over the top
to Westwood look at how high Westbrook
gets up off the floor and the hang time
it takes to wait for the pass wow that
was a great pass nice snitch year with
the Houston Rockets Jones flops by
Damari Carol two seconds to go for
Austin Rivers it'll count got it
everything going the Rockets way tonight
austin rivers rivers as in wet two
minutes to go
Hardin blows by tatum it kicks it out
tucker rue des with a push with live
lakes this late in the game just keep an
eye on come right into your picture how
about that one don't call a play they
know what they want
hopefully to make three to beat the
buzzer in the third quarter
what's on the attack
[Applause]
but it can rust when he takes the ball
coast to coast turns on the Jets hammers
at home the crowd here in New York went
crazy on that dump lot of Westbrook fans
in here Watson and that is 20 points now
for for Russell his 31st game of scoring
20 or more he's back to back let me get
it to my sweet spot and that's sweet
right there the strong finish how's jr.
very sad to hear that again
rose beer tried to put covington on a
pollster but he did not Ricketts cover